es wird immer wahrscheinlicher dass die
stringtheorie tatsächlich unser
universum und viele weitere erklärt auf
der suche nach der quantengravitation
sind forscher und forscherinnen jetzt
dieser theorie wieder einen großen
schritt näher gekommen
bei der untersuchung vom verhältnis von
ladung und masse in einem schwarzen loch
spricht alles dafür dass die gravitation
die schwächste kraft in allen möglichen
universen ist und das hat konsequenzen
denn das kann nur die stringtheorie
erklären tricks um science and future
geht es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
wir feiern 600.000 abonnements danke
dass er dabei seid und tricks um zu dem
gemacht hat was es ist ich habe für euch
etwas ganz besonderes als dank und zwar
für alle ein echtes geschenk danke dass
ihr dieses ganz besondere angebot
möglich gemacht habe dieses video ist
nämlich entstanden in kooperation mit
ricoh de dem digitalen abos für
smartphone oder tablet für regulär 999
gibt es nahezu alle magazine und
zeitschriften speziell für euch gibt es
die ersten beiden monate für nur einen
euro 99 zusammen
der link ist in der video beschreibung
oder hier und ich finde ja wirklich
nahezu alle sind bereich wissenschaft
und erfahre so von den aktuellen
entwicklungen und das super fundiert
egal ob space das weltraum magazin bild
der wissenschaft computer science
spektrum spektrum sterne und welt als 1
fokus der bbc und und und und wir haben
dieses mega spannende thema dort auf
weg.de im spektrum heft gefunden aber es
gibt noch mehr als 5000 weitere magazin
us weekly ist wie dass netflix für
magazine am ereignishorizont schwarzer
löcher passiert etwas sehr mysteriös die
schwarzen löcher strahlen sie geben
teilchen ab und schrumpfen so dass hat
stephen hawking 1974 herausgefunden nach
ihm wurde diese strahlung benannt die
hawking strahlung messen konnte das
bisher niemand schwarze löcher sind
nahezu ununterbrochen strahlung ist zum
beispiel viel zu schwach aber die
theoretische physik hat sie nachgewiesen
sie muss
assistieren ohne sie wären schwarze
löcher nicht möglich sie haben nämlich
keine andere wahl als im thermischen
gleichgewicht mit ihrer umgebung zu
existieren deshalb müssen sie einen
temperatur haben und das bedeutet dass
sich strahlung abgeben müssen ein
eigentlich unmögliches ding hawking fand
einen sonderfall der vakuum fluktuation
bei ihr entstehen virtuelle teilchen und
antiteilchen paare was ständig überall
geschieht und eben auch an der
oberfläche eines schwarzen loches
während diese teilchen paare im vakuum
nie zu echten teilchen werden passiert
am ereignishorizont eines schwarzen
loches etwas sehr spezielles da an
dieser grenze
auf der einen seite teilchen nicht aus
dem schwarzen loch entweichen können und
auf der anderen seite wohl trennen sich
die teilchen dort auf das eine teilchen
mit negativer energie fällt in das
schwarze loch das andere entkommt da
negative energie auch negative masse
bedeutet es gilt ja eh gleich einmal
c-quadrat masse also proportional zu
energie ist bedeutet dass zum einen
negative masse für das schwarze loch es
verliert also masse und durch das weg
fliegende teilchen die hawking strahlung
obwohl bewiesen ist schwarze löcher
verlieren masse verdampfen also
irgendwann einmal wenn sie sich keine
neue materie ein verleiht dieses
verhalten was allen bis dato gängigen
annahmen widersprach führt auf die spur
eines noch größeren rätsels der
endgültigen vereinigung von einsteins
relativitätstheorie und der
quantenphysik der kranken gravitation im
inneren eines schwarzen loches wird
nämlich ein stein quasi zerstörte raum
und zeit werden so derartig deformiert
dass hier nur die quantenphysik helfen
kann und neue forschungen könnten den
weg dorthin weisen es kommt nämlich
etwas hinzu was das ganze komplett ad
absurdum führt irgendwann ist nämlich
eine grenze des zerfalls erreicht
teilchen sind ja meistens irgendwie
geladen weshalb es ja so etwas wie
chemie überhaupt gibt die
unterschiedliche ladung führt dazu dass
sich teilchen anziehen und moleküle
größere strukturen bilden geladene
teilchen fallen aber auch ins schwarze
loch und sie können so eine ladung
tragen und diese ladung können sie durch
die hawking strahlung nicht verlieren
sie bleibt gleich und dann kommt
irgendwann die grenze weil sie keine
ladung verlieren können dann können sie
nicht weiter schrumpfen
bei extrem stabilen elementen in der
chemie die nicht mehr reagieren bleiben
sie absolut stabil die grenze ihres
verdampfen es ist erreicht sie können
nicht mehr schrumpfen also doch nicht
keine hawking strahlung mehr
am ende wäre das universum voller
kleiner unverfallbar schwarzer löcher
sie werden extrem male schwarze löcher
genannt weil sie ein extrem erreicht
haben in diesem fall ihre kleinste
mögliche größe doch ein forschungsteam
fand für diesen unglücklichen fall einen
ausweg denn ein universum voller kleiner
extremer schwarzer löcher konnte sich
niemand vorstellen die lösung
gravitation ist immer die schwächste
kraft in jedem möglichen universum war
das ist starker tobak weil damit eine
ziemlich heftige grundsätzliche annahmen
verbunden ist die so bisher noch nicht
angenommen wurde und diese annahme
öffnete das tor zu einer bahnbrechenden
entdeckung die stabilität schwarzer
löcher die die grenze des zerfalls
erreicht haben müssen hängt mit ihrer
entropie zusammen dem mars ihrer
unordnung denn umso größer ist desto
mehr teilchen dort kreuz und quer durch
die gegend fliegen desto öfter können
sich auch die teilchen paare bilden und
eines davon entweichen es ist also
logisch dass es einen zusammenhang
zwischen der stärke der ladung und der
entropie geben muss weil beide mit für
die stabilität eines schwarzen lochs
verantwortlich sind und damit kann man
rechnen und das im wahrsten sinne des
wortes denn jetzt konnte man diese
größen in beziehung zueinander setzen
mit mathematik dazu rief aktion vom
california institute of technology einer
der beteiligten forscher
plötzlich schien zwei sehr coole dinge
miteinander verbunden zu sein und damit
sind wir genau beim punkt schwarze
löcher als tor zu unserer welt als
öffnung zum verständnis im märz diesen
jahres rechnete nämlich gerd kuhn und
ricardo branco von der carnegie mellon
university in pittsburgh mit diesen
annahmen und kamen zu einer simplen
formel die energie und entropie
miteinander verbindet und diese formel
gilt für thermodynamische systeme wie
gase aber eben auch für schwarze löcher
mit dieser formel sind die
wissenschaftler der quantengravitation
wieder etwas näher gekommen und sie kann
in unserer realität überprüft werden
weil sie eben nicht nur für schwarze
löcher geht zum prinzip wieso können
schwarze löcher überhaupt
mal werden recht entspannt und da sind
wir wieder bei der mathematik mit
einsteins relativitätstheorie und denen
des elektromagnetismus der verladung
gilt kommt heraus die ladung eines
schwarzen loches muss immer kleiner oder
gleich der masse m sein masse und ladung
legen die größe des ereignisses
horizonts fest also die minimale und die
ladung bestimmt die größe eines weiteren
horizont eines ladungs horizonts gilt
also kuh muss kleiner gleich m sein kann
der ladungs horizont maximal gleich
geordnet dem ereignishorizont seien
darüber hinaus wurde der radius des
ereignishorizont zu einer komplexen zahl
einer zahl also aus einem negativen und
einem positiven bestandteil das geht
schlechterdings nicht es gibt allerdings
einen ausweg diese extremen schwarzen
löcher müssten ziemlich kleine sein weil
auch ihre ladung klein sein dürfte denn
im großen und ganzen müsste sich die
ladung aller atome ausgleichen bis auf
einen kleinen minimalen rest wenn das
aber so ist dann funktioniert aber die
kombination der gleichung der
relativitätstheorie und des
elektromagnetismus nicht mehr gut das
errechneten die wissenschaftler niemals
china h mit lupus moti alberto nicolas
und kummerower demnach kann dann die
ladung sogar größer als die masse sein
also doch komplexe zahlen die lösung ist
dass die formel bestandteile nur
bestimmte vorzeichen haben dürfen und
das ergebnis genau gravitation ist die
schwächste kraft in jedem möglichen
universum wenn die ladung co größer m
der masse ist heißt das auch dass die
gravitation die schwächste kraft ist und
das heißt universell ist größer als m
für alle teilchen das ist allerdings
erstmal theoretische physik wie also
sind die vorzeichen tatsächlich damit
sind wir wieder bei stephen hawking und
der entropie denn nicht nur ladung und
entropie hängen zusammen sondern auch
die oberfläche des ereignishorizont ist
direkt proportional zur entropie umso
größer der ereignishorizont desto größer
ist auch die entropie das fanden hawking
und zeitgleich auch jacob beckens seien
vor rund 50 jahren heraus allerdings
hatten sie sich einfach gemacht weswegen
ihre theorie nur für große schwarze
löcher
sie ignorierten einfach alle effekte auf
kurze distanzen
diese spielen bei immer kleineren
schwarzen löchern also genau den extrem
ahlen eine immer größere rolle
ist ja auch logisch die unebene
oberfläche einer orange spielt auf der
erdoberfläche als kugel keine rolle
auf einer murmel schon die murmel könnte
nicht mehr gleichmäßig rollen die
erdkugel schon der physiker robot world
berechnete all diese effekte dabei kam
heraus wie bei der murmel jetzt aber
bezogen auf die entropie umso kleiner
das schwarze loch desto weniger ist die
entropie proportional zur oberfläche die
effekte über kurze distanzen namen immer
mehr zu desto kleiner die schwarzen
löcher wurden ich finde das eine
ziemlich verblüffende erkenntnis umso
kleiner die skalen werden desto weniger
spielt das große ganze eine rolle
sondern die störungen die fluktuationen
spannend das dürfte nicht nur für
murmeln gelten und da entropie zur
ladung und zur größe eines schwarzen
loches in beziehung steht kam die
flüssiger grant rahmen clifford und
julio physiker an der university of
california in berkeley 2017 als die
malls prinzipien auf die ladung und die
masse an banden auf eine erstaunliche
erkenntnis ihre korrekturen an der
formel zum verhältnis von ladungen
massen stimmten mit denen von bord zu
100 prozent überein
und sie kommen auf positive vorzeichen
womit wir durch die mathematischen
überlegungen so langsam zur angewandten
für sie kommen denn wie bei der murmel
müssen die korrekturen also die
störungen auf kleinen skalen der im
verhältnis mehr werden die
schlussfolgerung die ladung kann größer
als die masse werden die gravitation
wäre die schwächste kraft in allen
möglichen universen und damit sind wir
bei der stringtheorie die ja als ein
heißer kandidat zur erklärung der
quantengravitation gilt wenn gelten
würde das die gravitation die schwächste
kraft in jedem denkbaren universum ist
dann wäre das ein starker hinweis auf
die gültigkeit der stringtheorie sie
erklärt nämlich laut rauch santos vom
institute of advanced study als einzige
die gravitation als schwächste kraft in
jedem universum
das ist jedenfalls das ergebnis der
sumpfland vermutungen im sumpfland
landen nämlich in der stringtheorie alle
gedankenexperimente für unmögliche
universen und übrig bleiben nur mögliche
universen sie müssen nicht in sümpfen
und das sind
alles universen mit einer schwachen
gravitation also mit der gravitation als
schwächster kraft und jetzt kommt der
hammer
die schwarzen löcher als tor zur welt
garrett guten und ricardo pankow von der
carnegie mellon university in pittsburgh
haben in ihrer berechnung vom märz
diesen jahres die formeln mit den
korrekturen zur ladung und entropie und
berechneten die auf einer
thermodynamischen basis mit energie und
temperatur sie erhielten eine
allgemeingültige formel für das
verhältnis von energie und entropie für
schwarze löcher bestätigen ihre
ergebnisse dass die ladung in schwarzen
löchern größer als die masse sein kann
denn masse ist eine form von energie und
wenn sie weniger wird wird auch die
energie weniger und das umgekehrt
proportional zu entropie sie wird im
verhältnis zur masse mehr es ist wie bei
der moment mit der orangenhaut und genau
so hoffen die physiker die überprüfung
ihrer ergebnisse nämlich hier auf der
erde
denn ihre formeln lassen sich auch auf
ultrakalte gase nahe dem absoluten
nullpunkt beziehen und dort ließe sich
das verhältnis von entropia und energie
dann in der realität überprüfen so oder
so bleibt oder ist das aber absolut
spannend die entdeckung der beziehung
von ladung und masse und schwarzen
löchern die zahlreichen informationen
für die weitere forschung an der
quantengravitation liefern und das ist
einfach nur bahn brechen sollte sich die
gravitation als schwächste kraft in
allen möglichen universum bestätigen
kämen wir der stringtheorie und der
quantengravitation einen großen schritt
näher
es ist und bleibt spannend und zwar mega
spannend das thema stammt aus riedle de
eine app die ich schon seit geraumer
zeit nutze weil man da wirklich nahezu
alles findet wie zum beispiel hier der
grenzfall für schwarze löcher im
spektrum heft und ich habe ein ganz
besonderes angebot für euch es geht bis
zum 31 januar weekly in den ersten
beiden monaten für nur einen euro 99
zusammen und dann erst zahlt ihr 999 und
auch nur wenn es euch gefällt der link
ist hier einfach draufklicken und der
link ist übrigens auch in der video
beschreibung übrigens redliches papier
frei kein einziger baum wird gerodet
also darauf klicken und los geht's bis
dann bleibt dran